right good evening everybody how are we
tonight welcome to tonight's planning
committee of strife addition council my
name's Andy comp I will be chairing the
meeting today so not quite as many
people as we normally have for planning
committee meetings but a select company
I would like you to do if possible are
there turn your phone's off or put them
to silent because again if we have the
great escape or rule Brittania
plastinated in the middle of a speech
it's not really good sometimes you might
think that might be more appropriate to
listen to but unfortunately but rather
your parents on the other thing is well
any people relatives to speak are
allowed to speak and again please do not
interrupt it's not been at school but
most people are really good on this so
if I'm strong teaching grandmother or
grandfather to success
thank you very much like to introduce
our top table please
fine bangs from committee services makes
a nice legal says there is Kuhlman
Senior Planner Matthew coin Senior
Planner Georgia planner missus take to
both toughs your roll please thank you
can Tate I'm the planning manager for
tonight's meeting my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that may arise and to assist
members in their decision taking I'm
bound by the Royal Town Planning
Institute code of Professional Conduct
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from offices or the
recommendation Thank You chairman brings
much interest catch the Mills
on the first application item for the
agenda
[Music]
17:03 double to three oblique you will
burn erode I don't eat I do know the the
owner of that field so he appears so I
will be sitting out on the kettle two
points mr. chairman one as i always do i
will be able to my laptop open with
details of the application in here
needless question answer needless
questions but also in reference the
third application in bishop situation I
am the member but I have made no public
or private comment today from this
scheme I discussed it with the system
and on the basis that comfortable for me
to continue all the committee thank you
I'm showing dentist pointless questions
or leaders questions right item three
minutes are you happy that I can sign
the minutes of the planning committee of
the 13th of November thank you all I'll
do that later right and I'm going to
crave your indulgence and ask if we can
move item number five which is uppercase
in 19 / 0 2 7 5 - f you aren't an
orchard way studly - the first item to
be discussed are you happy that I do
that thank you
and there are some coming reasons what
I've done that be cursed right so I walk
over to
the ways you don't need to speak write
this application was here because of the
parish council objection Parish Council
of not decided to attend solo can stand
as registers bacon that gap spoken to
counselor ed in I can't sir I didn't is
also agreed not to to speak as well as
left okay thank you put me off there all
right so the application was here
because our counsel objected not here in
the scheme of delegation we are made to
delegate the decision to officers as
part of that if they do not attend I'm
seeking to do that and seeking approval
from committee to delegate this decision
to office officers and the decision as
part of the application was to approve
to grant are you happy that I can do
that yes that's all agree to get some
community agrees to to the gate decision
to officers to grant and supplication
thank you
application number 17 / 0 3 2 2 3 / ful
vernier old lights on heat and previous
fall start Thank You chair this
application relates to a proposal for
the erection of 21 dwellings on land
adjacent to Bernie Road in light horn
Heath the application site is identified
by black dot on the map the application
site is identified here on the citation
in red on the plan is located in the
northern edge of lights horn Heath
Village by way of reference this is the
layout plan with access achieved from
Bernie Road the proposals for a mix of
two three and four-bedroom two-story
dwellings and just so members are aware
this is the application site this is top
picture here's looking in ass literally
direction this is looking in a westerly
direction this is that the existing
dwellings of Bernie Road again looking
site is to the west and this is looking
from the southern part of the site the
school is to the west southwest and
again just looking along the eastern
part you can sort of see the school
outline here so members this application
was previously brought before the East
area planning committee on the 20th of
March 2019 when members resolved grants
planning permission subject to the
completion of a section 106 agreement
for the provision of 35% affordable
housing on the site together with
contributions towards public
rights-of-way
sustainable welcome packs of site public
open space and biodiversity offsetting
the application has been brought back
before members due to the applicant
declining to enter into a section 106
secret
with respect to the 35% affordable
housing on the site so that equates the
provision of seven affordable houses on
the sides whilst the applicant has
adequately demonstrated that there's
been a lack of interest from the
council's registered Housing Association
partners to take on these dwellings in
these instances fixed equity sales
schemes are considered to be a
legitimate alternative tenure product in
essence this would result in the
dwellings be marketed at 60% of their
open market value in perpetuity the
applicant doesn't agree with the
principle of fixed equity housing and
therefore declined to enter into a
section 106 agreement on this basis and
no alternative affordable housing scheme
is being brought forward by the
applicants
so in summary therefore it's concerned
sidered that the failure of the
applicant to enter into a section 106
agreement to provide affordable housing
on the site would be contrary to our
policy CS 18 of our core strategy and
also government guidance contain within
the MPP F in addition the development
would also fail to provide financial
contributions towards public
rights-of-way sustainable welcome packs
off site opens public open space and
biodiversity offsetting and therefore
would also be contrary to call strategy
policies cs6 c 7c s 26 and c s 27 so
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
planning commission for the reason
details on page six of the committee
report Thank You chair Thank You Louise
and can we have our first speaker police
which is cancer counselor Mike might be
here
oK you've it's got three minutes so when
you're ready and if you can press the
middle button it should have okay
Thank You mr. chairman my company's
private counsel support the officer
recommendation forward feasel the Parish
Council formally objectives the
application made at the Planning
Committee of March 2019 for the 21
houses the copy of which is in your
committee report and we continue to be
committed to that opposition the parish
council would like to make the Planning
Committee aware that the applicant
commenced work on clearing this fight on
Monday the 2nd of December 2019 and as
stated by the officers report as the
applicant does not wish to enter into an
agreement with a section 106
requirements we are aware that no by
biodiversity offsetting has been met
given that the site is part of a wider
designated local wildlife site this is
hugely disappointing the committee will
also be aware through the offices report
that this site has a number of
applications associated with it
including an extinct permission for 10
houses Park ants will have huge concerns
around the applicant's prevarication of
developing this site presumably to
maximize profit abilities with the
various applications that been submitted
over the past 15 years or so furthermore
with regard to the extinct permission
relating back to 2003 the very lengthy
timescale for this commission means that
changes in planning law and requirement
says this time will not apply for
example by diversity of setting
provision of affordable housing and the
requirements for construction and
environmental management plan whilst the
applicant has advised the parish class
that he will attend parish meetings to
discuss this like to date that hasn't
happened when the parish counts are
therefore concerned what the applicant
intends to do with the site since it is
laid dormant for 15 years and my
clearance work is taking place if the
intention is to build out what type of
housing will be provided and over what
time
if any development does go ahead what
provision will be made for adequate
infrastructure Road and traffic
management and how does this linking
with the infrastructure currently being
installed for the new GLH settlement
finally the Parish Council was too
strongly reiterate their point about the
disruption and inconvenience to local
residents in the area while already
experienced a huge amount of upheaval
with a bell way 140 homes building site
adjacent alive horn Heath and the
associated road and footpath works along
the B for 100 lighting he's a
professional request that apparent that
the committee consider these points when
reaching a decision on this application
and support the officer recommendation
for refusal thank you Thank You
councillor
I said well within the earth time which
is very much appreciated any questions
too
no you're free to go thank you very much
right
obviously the ward number hasn't
registered to speak and there are no
objectives we've gone two points of
clarification for the officers please
write them should we go back to the
plights of clarification for the offices
and I was it quite quite I think it was
quite pretty self-explanatory
sir fielding just quickly looking to see
how many houses were agreed in the when
we gave it permission last time in March
so therefore the hence the seven houses
yeah we resolved to approve the
twenty-one but with the section 106
agreements yes I was a there's an
organic stunt permission of ten so
[Applause]
development certificate to verify that
the there had been a commencement of the
permission it was granted for the
reserve matters and also the outline in
2001 so the ones which have actually
been implemented in a 2003 zero zero
seven seven zero REM which was proved on
the 30th of March 2003 on page 10 of the
report so it's that one together with
a 2001 permission which was allowed on
appeal that's the baseline one which is
the zero one stroke zero zero zero three
five stroke very those are the ones
which the local development certificate
refers to and that's what has been
implemented so in order to to be
implemented they had to have a material
commencements and also all conditions
discharged there after it's it's extant
in perpetuity building legal status of
them starting work there is it same as
if you start work on a development even
just digging a trench that now they've
started to clear the site is there some
sort of commitment that they've got
there or anything that would affect our
decision they have they have the
parishes that confirmed that they have
commenced to further the works on the
site on the 2nd of December of this
month and that was already assessed in
2007 so in order for us back in 2007 to
have issued development certificate for
the site they must have commenced
development together with discharge of
all conditions any pre commencement
conditions so and then there was a very
limited amount of conditions attached to
the original outline which is
effectively the 2001 permission because
that was allowed on appeal and I think
there was only about six conditions for
four or six conditions on that imposed
by the inspector that permission has run
out
no that permissions now extent so they
could go for the ten huh yes in which
case they wouldn't need any social
housing yes so we move on to the pie
plates
who wants to start on this one them cats
the cattle I think it's some
extraordinary size with no section 106
agreement between the developer and the
district council we have a core strategy
which clearly sets out a developer's
obligations based on a district-wide
criteria this isn't a specific current
criteria just for this site and I think
just because of developers declined to
take part in the normal process
it shouldn't be given it shouldn't be
ignored what is the point in having that
process if we were to let this
development go ahead if the developer
comes back and agrees for section 106
then we can we can look at it again but
since he hasn't done so or maybe my
feelings is that we should accept the
officers recommendation clear exactly
for the chat and I'm very happy to
composure but that's not the idea of a
contrary view case the philodendron
council opportunity as louise knows
we've had a similar site in one of my
villages where they've done the
secretary thing and it's working I hope
well we've had another where they put
ten houses up and they gave a lump sum
in lieu of 106 agreement and that again
is going ahead I think that if they've
got permission for ten houses and you
know they can't be bothered to
contribute as per the group the granting
we've just had I agree with councilor
kettle it should refuse it and our
second it passage innit
sorry I'm also happy to support the
refusal so we've had a proposal and a
second to go along with offices
recommendation to refuse this
application for the reasons mentioned in
the report she will get through it all
those in favor you know miss chairman
committee resolves to refuse application
at 17 / 0 3 2 2 3 / fu
[Applause]
of interest why did that come to
committee
it was initially changes
when they move on to our final item of
the agenda which is 19 slash 0 2 4 3 6
/ul howls mayor 25 Garden Road Bishop
positions inside them
construction of a new single detached -
a link to the rear of number 25 Canyon
Road and the new drop curb - number 5 24
25 going red thank you the application
saw is located to the southern edge of
positions and as indicated by the black
dot before you the site is located
within the physical confines of bishops
and presently forms the rear garden and
number 25 Gaiden road interests make
things easier this is number 25 game
road the application is it the soy
contains a shared access the rear
boundary which runs not cut roads and
says 23 and 25 Gaiden Road the access
says a single-story Gary tweets - adding
a nice hit directly on the boundary of
very properties fronting like Oak Road
so once again this is a nugget road and
that's that garage was talking about
says 123 and number 25 this is an area
was shot the application gaining 24 the
gate and Rose down there and I cook Road
and that's the application site that the
garage number 25 number 23 gain road
itself is predominated story red brick
might render dwellings while not cut
Road consists largely of two and two and
our story dwellings constrict that a red
brick and also white render in addition
a number of smaller islands including
bungalows which are these I've also been
recently read along Market Road
furthermore 270 sap strands have been
improved in the Nate and neighboring
property 2016 so two semi detached
dwellings have been improved here and
you will see on the plant what they look
like apparently this is the block plan
bus to to so many touchdowns that was
talked about this is the proposed
dwelling carpark and movie situated
front and lot road ascertained same on
gaining Road the principal elevation
will face the north floor plans in C
freeway during dwell in park in so forth
these the elevations Prince relevation
which is face to the north was a gable
pitch diamund a will pitch this
elevation shows in relation to number 25
to rear and that would be this would be
the front elevation facing on Market
Road as well this is straight into the
indicative street scene so to prove
somebody's hearts to Ellen's gate and
road as you can clearly see the property
will be set lower and the neighboring
properties this is one of the photos of
the application side of the garage shows
it quite clearly what the site is like
at the minute
no one of the garden area where it will
be situated this is a site to the front
of malakut Road so just put in there
frightened onto it I'll also just point
out here development has been improved
for a few more drawings which runs
aruhya I show you them in two seconds
draining would be situated here if
approved in 25k Road this is Babas homes
development site so they are now
situated just here and which Google
Earth sadly doesn't show the development
and whence the rear which a number of
properties have also been approved and
under construction presently this is the
i-rack the opposite and so
different contrasts of the dwellings in
strain in the neighborhood one of the
bungalows which is just here as improved
two separate bungalows run there which
you see on Google Earth is that this is
the development that's running directly
adjacent to it which now both homes have
improved to the rear as well if just
good measure I decided put in Google
Earth shot so you can see this is
directly adjacent the white dwelling and
also shows the volley of babies homes
development that's the end of the
slideshow in conclusion the application
is within the physical confines as well
as the draft built-up area boundary and
therefore the principal development
follows a policy CS 15 CS 16 is turn the
donors also considered not to cause
undue harm and or dullness the
neighboring properties and in
consideration recent labour approvals
would fit with an immediate street scene
due to its scale under zoning daraa no
updates thank you please which is catch
that madam took more from positions in
price council I say I've been here
before catch the dog one I'm sure you
know that score three minutes will give
you a warning shot with 30 seconds to go
thank you far away when you're at the
place okay good evening share members
and officers and firstly the parish
council would like to acknowledge the
amendments that have been made to the
design of the proposed development in
response to its initial comments however
there remains a fundamental issue with
the proposal which is that the village
has already delivered over 180 percent
of its housing requirements as specified
in policy CS 16 of the adopted core
strategy should the committee be minded
to grant this application they will be
setting a precedent which undermines the
spatial strategy there the spatial
strategy element of the core strategy
and which is contrary to the councillors
development plan the applicants agent
goes to great lengths to emphasize a
specific local need of the proposed
market dwelling and uses this as the
basis of their justification they cite
at least two of the nearby properties
which were granted on us in
however both these other properties are
subject to a local needs agreement so
that they remain in perpetuity to meet
the housing needs of local people were
the applicant to enter into such an
agreement as suggested and supported by
the Parish Council then both CS 15 part
G as the SPD part s would have been
satisfied for the reasons previously
stated the parish council cannot support
any playing application for additional
market housing
it could be minded to support one that
comes with a local needs agreement we
also have one or two concerns about some
of the details in the committee report
as an existing residential site within
the blue of the relevant section of a
s10 cannot be met while there is
conflict with CS 16 or CS 15 as it
requires conformance to both we query
the relevance of the planning history
given as it concerns a different site
which received planning permission under
a now obsolete local plan similarly the
reference to outline permission for a
site further south unlike a road that's
the partially built bungalows you saw in
the image also predates the current core
strategy with regard to climate change
and sustainable construction we note an
absence of defined sustainable energy
measures or reference to the location
and kilowatt rating of the EB charging
provision on the plan submitted as a
full application and required in order
to the current policy compliance these
should be part of the application else
the policy is not met your officer
reminds us that this is to be determined
in accordance with the adopted
development plan I would like to concur
that and hope that you give weight to
the policies with which this proposal
currently conflicts and determine it
accordingly I would finally like to
reiterate that a local needs agreement
consistent with the applications
assertion of that being a local need
would have tipped the balance in favor
of this application as a sustainable
development on the basis for mitigating
local need in the future well within
town council thank you very much I've
practiced that one shame one or two
cancers that did happen
right
any questions for cancer mills Jim good
did you say that you've exceeded a
hundred acres put a 2% you know had an
80% one hundred ninety percent per CS 16
as a cat one local service village 113
houses rounding up we're at 200 and
cinetic so far 220 thank you for the
correction with a windfall of nearly 300
on top
you know Sonia is 220 I thought you were
saying you go and hire you and indicate
into I've got one question
my concern is about section 106
agreements on local needs and I'll just
have to make sure I'm concerned I'll
probably be raising this with the office
tonight but well it's an honor
obligation and what's the reasonable
obligation to be pulling on and I'm not
sure what it is so I'll be raising up an
officer so just as I going to tell you
that rather than leave any further
questions for the outcomes are doing it
thank you yeah but thank you very much
you're free to go back to that wonderful
I suppose over that net yeah gansan
points of clarification officer JUnit is
indicated yeah just just a couple of
questions
the I do note that the officer is saying
that if permission is forthcoming
he considered prudent that a materials
condition and architectural details
condition are imposed and also about the
hedge will be largely retained so that
is presumably dependent on what the
decision is but there is a reason for
for you putting that in there yeah
absolutely fundamentally to minimize the
impact the development the discharge
conditions if they submit a landscape in
detail I can assess it making sure we
have it in word in that the ledge will
be retained and there may be other
mitigating planting and so forth we can
negotiate you in the course of the
discharge to make surely it looks nicer
to be honest and minimizes that impacts
along I could not cut Road Chancellor
Mills thank you Joe did you say that the
gardens I would have done exactly the
same thing down that road yeah I
completely appreciate where the Congress
is occurring from they were done earlier
days but the assessment is written in
physical confines so you can see here
it's a neighbor in the property to
semi-detached Whalen which is two rear
gardens you've also got approvals here
to the rear gardens once upon time these
with reiha gardens as well thank you
yeah two points the part councils raised
the issue about climate change masses
and the lack of any conditions that
really support that could you comment on
that and please mister yeah of course
there's a few issues I mean we I have
recommended certainly beasts even
conceived of charging points and you can
do it through landscape and details the
issues that we have at the minute is
although there is a climate change SPD
in the works it's in the works
and sadly there is no enforceable policy
at the minute that we have in our course
trustee that enforces developers to do
these climate change measures and
therefore they could it doesn't meet the
test it's as simple as that until the
SPD gives it first way we're struggling
as officers to invoke these conditions
and suddenly that is where we are with
that okay the second one is relating
from local need and there's ten
acknowledged this is within the built up
area boundary and this is a lsv one but
as councillor
- counsel has pointed out mr. Doug ball
they shortness has delivered 220 homes
already on a limit well on a advised
figure of 135 which was considered to be
the sustainable amount so if we look at
the local need I supposed to open market
because that's been delivered two
hundred and twenty homes why'd you feel
it difficult to as the parish council
wanted that they should not be a local
needing the only the simple truth is is
not enforceable it doesn't meet the test
because the principles already been
established we have over at section 106
applications where they've now removed
it because the change in policy within
the physical confines I've removed that
section 106 is so if we imposed a
section 106 or local knees dwell in they
could simply say we don't want to enter
it it's unjustified or we'd impose it
and they could have it remove the very
next day I mean looking at is ten under
community paragraph a small scale scheme
for housing employment community for
foods to meet a need identified by local
community are you saying that Clause
what I'm saying there is a few other
elements in just a yes 1001 this came
through as a see free market dwelling
not through a parish plan or anything
else and open C free markets well in to
that clause also ties in with areas of
the core strategy and all of the
settlements to dwellings where you are
most solid in the arm categories of
service villages so that's how you do
the local need services because the
principle there
they consider completely unsustainable
so you do a local needs to either in
this case it doesn't meet their
requirements the policy states if it's
in the physical confines or defying
built-up area boundary appreciate is
only draft at a minute the prince was
established and therefore they can't
have open sea free market dwellings or
in this location
I just might I just confirm that we are
actually basically assessing it on a c3
dwelling just open market and not a
local market wedding today was explained
that it's just the policy it's not
within the policy to actually have a
local market 20 come this side catch the
cattle are smart question and that was
the focus section 106 so basically that
would be if we imposed it there are to
be an unfair obligation or they could
just ignore it basically they could
actually not into the section 106
agreement and then basically appealed
for non determination because they've
been entered into it so it would go to
appeal and a very insisting that a
policy should be attached to it which is
not relevant
then I'm not too sure about our hopes of
actually winning that appeal another
point to Joe sorry back on page 36 and
we've talked about the SVT for climate
change and it's having too much teeth
because we haven't probably adopted it
yet I noticed you say that
notice that applicant expects to
incorporate sustainable energy measures
in terms of element but will decide the
specific type of diti
detailed construction that such an event
of planning permission being granted so
if we got to the detailed construction
stage
and we got into gear and actually
approved the both the SPD could we then
insist that as part of the construction
they met climate change standards Joe if
I can respond current situation the
current position is policy CS cs2 which
relates to sustainability standards in
buildings States the council will
encourage high standards of
sustainability
the council will promote an energy
hierarchy
it won't impose it the SPD is still a
student draft for you would be a breach
of policy cs2 you will be I think over
enforcing in my view there isn't a
policy there isn't a policy to to
require these to be provided is
encouraged and it's encouraged yeah
sorry I was just probably add to that we
don't know for certain when that SP that
he's going to be adopted so we're
relying on a criteria yeah I've just
invited every was up to Co master
quezacotl kosis Junaid was at cabinet on
Monday when it was explained that the
SPD when it is adopted is actually
providing additional focus on our errors
as in areas relating to climate change
in the existing storm strategy it is not
introducing any new policies you're
nodding so we're not talking about any
game changes in policy coming through
when the SPD is developed so we have to
go back to it from core strategy which
all the SPD is looking to hide
relevant bits and if we go to cs2 it
doesn't say anything about encouragement
it says under paragraph 2 Heating and
Cooling proposal should demonstrate how
development has been designed
comprehensively to cope with rising a
more extreme temperatures achieved
through land form layout orientation
construction materials and ventilation
systems that do not increase carbon
dioxide emissions now that is an adopted
policy and I think what question that
comes out of that is in the proposals
how have they demonstrated compliance
with cs2 which is as I've just said an
adopted policy as within 2016 there's
nothing new about it through you to the
reference to encouraging high standards
is in fact in policies yes to be which
relates specifically to sustainability
standards in buildings which would be
the appropriate part of the policy that
we were to consider in relation to
individual proposals that does say state
will encourage will I appreciate the the
overarching concern in terms of heating
and cooling elements that counsel to
catalyst referred to and point to in cs2
we're directly looking at sustainability
standards for individual buildings in
this case I've got that wording in front
of me but the cs2 comprises two parts
mitigating and adapting to climate
change a and B sustainability standards
and buildings and presumably a nurse mr.
Nash tells us otherwise both parts of
the policy are should be given equal
weight in determining in the application
and therefore whilst we encourage
sustainability standards going back to
what I said earlier paragraph 2 of
it makes it quite clear and I'll repeat
the question how does the application
demonstrate that it's been designed to
accept etc minimize carbon dioxide
emissions using construction materials
and installation systems that's the
Pauling precis or what it says but I did
read an item more detail the first time
around can you just tell me how has it
addressed those issues Isis out oilmen -
there's two two elements one since 2016
when this was done a lot of these
regulations now been carried over into
Building Control so Building Control as
a separate formulated station and they
carry these let's lay legislations now
so construction of climate change is
covered under a separate legislation
that isn't a planning consideration in
this instance such wonderful
secondly in regard to this actual
application to be fair - and I've spoken
to the architect he has tried to design
it on such a way that it minimizes and
utilizes the Sun orientation that's what
was doing the soffit pitch because I was
a bit concerned over that and he's
appreciate where he was coming from also
he did stay in designs access statement
that he would use sustainable measures
sadly we go back to the first point and
which I've got in the report is that one
I can't enforce and their measures and
two and the loss of the air at the
cordon and that lot a lot of it is
covered under permitted development and
I have stated a lot in the report
yes no should we go on two points with
our points of Kasich on to the debate
that seems determined optimistic clear
summary that we have two unenforceable
pots of our core strategy one relating
to the part of a s10 which I'd hoped
would be able to focus towards local
needs we can't do that and also section
of a or C s2 is also now unenforceable
because that's gone off to Building
Control there is an issue here I think
we need to understand that probably a
separate meeting not to the plan
committee
how many policies in the core strategy
have now been effectively superseded by
other bits and pieces but if the mr.
Brooke had been quite clear about this
we are we cannot enforce sustainability
standards we can't afford local needs
standards we have very little option but
to allow this application to go forward
in line with his recommendation quite
agree you know some real prices that gas
kettle but I think you know some
interesting points and I think we
absolutely good idea if you write to the
Planning Manager to see some guidance
for future meetings on these these items
that you're referring to just super got
some clarity I think I think that would
be a reasonable thing to do so I think
we'll leave that argument there that one
and I think there's some valid points we
do need to challenge we don't need to be
aware of these things so as part of our
gt22 challenge in a row great as well
I saw openly leave it there and go on to
catch the JUnit
it's just that it's exactly it was
exactly those gaps that persuaded the
task and finished working group that we
did need at least an SPD to be able to
move us forward granted it doesn't give
the the the surety that a DPD would do
or a core stretchy review would do but
at least it made some move forward which
currently the confusion at national
level and confusion that is you know
with changes of legislation at least it
will give some clarification and make
things somewhat better having the SPD
invade once it's been through its
consultation stages tense the mouse
thanks for chairman look good cants I
like this application it it's a bit like
well is born and ships and how many more
houses can you know Bishop to take but I
can't see if for playing a reason to
object to it I've just can't think of
one but it's just added on to make
bishops even more busy out here it seems
you filling in their gardens and you
know we all need a bit of greenery but
can't think of any good reason so I go
forward to support the officers
recommendation mr. chairman
very adjustable sorry I'm stopping
trying to stop it whistling this drives
me nuts the garden is is looks as if he
has a pretty derelict place from the
photographs and therefore putting
something this slightly smaller than all
the surrounding houses I think it's a
good idea I'm well frustrated that we
can't put 106 on it
kirpan this was happened before it looks
as though have you ever done a site
visit to confirm the state of garden
before you made that comment have you
have you I think he's answer the
question he studies not to a picture so
I think that yeah I think yeah I think
you've raised the point I think counts
the field is answered adequately so
right any we've had a proposal on we've
had a second to agree the recommendation
and obviously we've gone through in
quite detail and we discussed the
section 106 obligation and whether it's
an unfair obligation and various issues
to do with the SPD and we've asked that
cancer kettle all rights to plant in
mind is to seek some clarification on
the policies issued and then obviously
that will come back to respond and
complain the community our planning
committee beast and there we go and
we'll be going in the future
so thank you for that so we have that
recommendation to agree with the
officers from the recommendation to
grant this application all those in
favor against
abstentions
one chan committee resolves to grant
application 19 / 0 2 4 36 / fu hour and
there's no agent business closed meeting
1995 you forgot to say that since you
failed to finish them